[MUSIC PLAYING]
COLT MCANLIS: They're
everywhere
TODD KERPELMAN: And just
keep pointing.
And we are live.
Hello and welcome to Google
Games Chat number seven, the
Halloween edition.
COLT MCANLIS: It's spooky.
TODD KERPELMAN: Where none of
us are wearing costumes, but
I'm wearing orange because
of Halloween.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Or the
baseball game?
TODD KERPELMAN: Or the Giants.
That is one of the convenient
things about the Giants
playing in the World Series,
is you can wear orange and
you've got both bases covered.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Orange and
black, it's perfect.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah, Halloween
or Giants fan--
both.
WOLFF DOBSON: Does that mean
it's always Halloween in
Oklahoma state?
TODD KERPELMAN: I
suppose it is.
COLT MCANLIS: I have strong
opinions about Oklahoma that I
won't bring out on the air.
So let's just refrain
from Oklahoma jokes.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Cause
he loves it.
TODD KERPELMAN: Halloween
episode.
WOLFF DOBSON: To all of our
Oklahoma visitors, we'd like
to say, we love Oklahoma.
COLT MCANLIS: Unless you got
something to say, Oklahoma,
and then put it on the street.
TODD KERPELMAN: Hey,
here's a fun fact.
That pre-roll video we watched--
if you watch that a
week later, Louis Gray crawls
out of your computer monitor
and knifes you to death.
[INAUDIBLE]
COLT MCANLIS: Until you show
it to someone else.
TODD KERPELMAN: That's true.
WOLFF DOBSON: You watch it and
then you get an SMS that says,
"7 days."
TODD KERPELMAN: Therefore, you
have to forward this video to
somebody else or else you're
not going to make it.
And you know, we really should
probably stop just showing
that pre-roll in the
first place.
WOLFF DOBSON: Why do we keep
showing that pre-roll?
[INAUDIBLE]
TODD KERPELMAN: It's so hard
to get repeat customers.
COLT MCANLIS: It's important
that people know
what we talk about.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yes.
All right.
So we're going to start with
some introductions.
Hi.
Todd Kerpelman, moderator.
To my left, Dr. Wolff Dobson.
What are you dressing
for for Halloween?
Or are you?
WOLFF DOBSON: Right now
I'm dressing up as--
I was thinking about a spider.
I'm not sure I have enough PVC
tubes to form all the legs.
TODD KERPELMAN: Possibly
a mangled spider.
WOLFF DOBSON: I'm going
to be a spider after
an unfortunate accident.
TODD KERPELMAN: Or a tick
TODD KERPELMAN: To my right we
got Colt McCanlis What are you
dressing up for,
for Halloween?
COLT MCANLIS: A drunk father.
It's going to be great.
Run up to the door, kids.
[INAUDIBLE]
WOLFF DOBSON: Have you done the
trick-or-treat where you
carry the bottle of wine
and the wine glass?
COLT MCANLIS: That's
what we're doing.
That's actually the plan.
WOLFF DOBSON: I did that
for a couple years.
COLT MCANLIS: Run on, kids.
Daddy's in the street.
TODD KERPELMAN: And John--
John McCutchan, what are you
dressing up for, for Halloween?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Oh, I--
nothing.
TODD KERPELMAN: You sure?
You sure you're not going
to be a hobo?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I might, yeah.
I am working on my costume
right now.
COLT MCANLIS: John's going
to go as a native client
acceleration module.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes.
You won't see me.
WOLFF DOBSON: Wait, are you
trying to say that's Harry?
COLT MCANLIS: I like it.
It's rugged.
If we get attacked by zombies
during the show, I'm getting
behind this guy.
TODD KERPELMAN: That is true.
He's got the lumberjack,
like--
give you an axe, a baseball
bat, you are the antihero.
COLT MCANLIS: If you watch "The
Walking Dead," you'll
notice that the amount of
zombies killed by plaid
outranks solid colors.
Do the research, internet.
Prove me right.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: What
about stripes?
TODD KERPELMAN: That
is probably true.
WOLFF DOBSON: The amount of
drama per episode goes up
exponentially and the number
of zombies goes
down at the same rate.
I'm disappointed.
TODD KERPELMAN: Well let's move
on to today's tech demo,
which is really less of
a tech demo and more--
we're just going to
play some games.
Specifically, Colt wanted
to show off
his favorite [? NaCl ?]
Halloween-themed game.
So take it away, Colt.
COLT MCANLIS: Thank you.
For the Halloween show I,
wanted to make sure that
everyone had a great chance
to get a taste of
Halloween on the web.
So Jimmy, can we switch
over to feed, please?
Fantastic.
What you're looking at here is
a fantastic game by Spacetime
Studios called "Dark Legends."
"Dark Legends" is a vampire
MMO that you can get playing on
your phone or in the Chrome
web browser using
native client.
So I've spent some time in this
game, unfortunately--
well, fortunately it's a great
game to spend time with--
but I got a level 31 vampire
here, and she's rockin'.
Now the reason this is a great
Halloween game is, you get
some visuals in here that you
don't get with certain other
MMOs, right.
Like how many other MMOs
do you see that have
a fountain of blood?
Plus, the entire point of the
game is this sort of nice,
atmospheric concept that you're
going out and battling
the decaying undead, as opposed
to the unholy undead,
which vampires just
generally are.
You also notice that none of
these vampires are sparkling.
Big, important thing for
me, as I was ranting
about in our last talk.
So all through the environment
you get these really cool
environmental things.
Like of course Halloween is
here, so they've got the
environments with the pumpkins,
as well as just some
really cool ambience, like these
vampires down at the end
of the street found an
unsuspecting victim to make
friends with.
They're just dancing
So the cool thing is, you
obviously run around and do
instances with other
players-- sort of
like raids and dungeons.
Of course, all of these
instances are isolated, so
you're guaranteed to get some
good friends and not an
experience of waiting
in line or waiting
into a queue or whatnot.
But in general, this is
a fantastic game.
If you're looking to do some
nice a browser-based Halloween
gaming, I highly
recommend "Dark
Legends." It's fantastic.
The guys over at Spacetime
Studios-- they know what
they're doing when
it comes to MMOs.
And the coolest part is that you
can pick this up and run
right on your phone, too.
So if you're sitting here and
you're playing and all of a
sudden you decide, hey, I'm
sorry, I need to go to the DMV
for some reason.
You can just turn it, off pick
up your phone, walk to the
DMV, and scare everybody
there.
So this is my Halloween browser
game pick of the month.
So go, play it. "Dark Legends"--
check it out on the
Chrome Web Store.
TODD KERPELMAN: I see
you got killed.
I guess it's hard to play
and talk at the
same time, isn't it?
COLT MCANLIS: It is.
Usually I'm ignoring everyone.
But while you talk,
I'm going to play.
TODD KERPELMAN: Well I was just
going to point out your
character's choice of outfit.
COLT MCANLIS: Listen, that's
actually the highest powered
outfit in the game.
Don't judge.
It gives me +3 intelligence
and +30 damage.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: +3
something else?
TODD KERPELMAN: +20 charisma.
COLT MCANLIS: Careful,
careful.
TODD KERPELMAN: If you
know what I'm saying.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: No, I don't.
COLT MCANLIS: She fights the
undead, and that's important.
You have to look the part.
TODD KERPELMAN: I feel like
maybe a plaid shirt might be
appropriate.
COLT MCANLIS: Actually,
that's great feedback.
Spacetime Studios, you need
to put in a plaid shirt.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I could
be the model.
I'll just come in.
COLT MCANLIS: We'll
fly you down.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Look like you
rolled out of bed, and you
could kill zombies.
COLT MCANLIS: I think that's
really what we need to start
up is the Google GDL zombie
killing program.
You're issued a plaid shirt and
"Dark Legends" and you can
go from there.
TODD KERPELMAN: Go
and kill zombies.
Well thank you very
much for the demo.
I will go and play it and
I too will pick up
that outfit, I guess.
COLT MCANLIS: You should.
It's a great outfit.
TODD KERPELMAN: Can I wear
it on a male character?
Can I wear speedos?
COLT MCANLIS: So there is a
male version of this which
looks just as creepy.
They've got other versions.
They've got a funny little X--
super vampire version that looks
like the standard Bram
Stoker style with the big
poofies and everything.
I don't even know.
I'm not a fashion guy.
But a fantastic game.
WOLFF DOBSON: The big poofies?
COLT MCANLIS: The poofies,
you know.
They've got the jacket and
then this big, like--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Poof.
COLT MCANLIS: Poof.
I don't even know-- frills?
Lace?
TODD KERPELMAN: I know what
you're talking about.
The frilly stuff.
The 18th century gentlemen
dandy outfits.
COLT MCANLIS: Yes.
If you know what that's actually
called, put it on the
stream and Jimmy will reward
you with shooting your
username out on the internet.
WOLFF DOBSON: Or someone's
username.
Not totally sure.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Are you talking
about an ascot?
WOLFF DOBSON: No, an
ascot is different.
That's the tie.
That's the double tie-thing
that you get.
It's like a thing that comes
down and you have a little
diamond stud, if I recall
from Scrooge McDuck.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: That's right.
COLT MCANLIS: Duck
Tales, woo-oo.
WOLFF DOBSON: I think we've
gone off track.
TODD KERPELMAN: This entire
show is off track.
WOLFF DOBSON: Why is it
that Scrooge McDuck
doesn't wear pants.
Does anybody know?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: None
of them wear pants.
TODD KERPELMAN: Before
we start this week's
five-for-five, I just want to
point out-- last week we
talked about the future of
college as one of our
five-for-fives.
And this past weekend--
I'm just going to show
this, I don't know
if you can see this.
Time Magazine--
their cover was basically
the exact same topic.
So Time Magazine, stop
stealing our ideas.
Come up with your own.
You've got your own staff.
COLT MCANLIS: Or better
yet, steal
them, but give us credit.
At least own up to the
fact that you stole
the idea from GDL.
TODD KERPELMAN: That is true.
Reinventing college,
inspired by Google
Games Chat number six.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It's true.
It's absolutely true.
TODD KERPELMAN: I think so.
Do we have the cool graphic
intro yet for our
five-for-five?
I'm getting a thumbs down.
WOLFF DOBSON: Five!
Four!
Five!
TODD KERPELMAN: That's
pretty good.
And this is--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Play that back
every episode from now on.
WOLFF DOBSON: Only if we
all do it together.
TODD KERPELMAN: That's going
to be even more awkward.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I think
just you going like--
[LAUGHTER]
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: We'll
mute the sound.
WOLFF DOBSON: Speaking
of zombies.
TODD KERPELMAN: So this
is a Halloween-themed
five-for-five.
WOLFF DOBSON: I sense
an animated gif.
[LAUGHTER]
TODD KERPELMAN: I'm trying
to keep us on topic.
Stop it.
I'm going to start the stopwatch
once we reveal our
first question.
We'll chat about it until the
stopwatch goes off and then
we'll move on.
So Halloween theme,
first question--
so what's up with all
these zombies?
Why are there so many zombies
in so many games?
Why do so many games
have zombie modes?
Why do we love zombies
so much?
WOLFF DOBSON: I have a thesis.
The thesis is, back when you
were programming on a
PlayStation One, you
were lucky--
using painters' algorithm
instead of a z-buffer, you
were lucky to have two enemies
onscreen at a time.
Once we switched to modern
graphics cards with lots of
cores, suddenly rendering
a whole bunch of dudes--
not nearly as big a deal.
In fact, if you've done a lot
of graphics programming, you
know all about level
of detail.
As you zoom closer to somebody,
you actually swap
models out as you get closer
and closer and closer, with
more and more polygons
on them.
But the reward for that is,
fewer and fewer people are
visible behind them as you
zoom closer and closer.
And so if you pull the camera
all the way back and show 300
zombies, dudes are probably
made out of
20, 30 polygons apiece.
But it looks fine.
And we can push that kind
of graphics even on
a Nexus 7 or something.
We just have so much more
graphics power.
And therefore, zombies
are fun.
TODD KERPELMAN: So you're
saying zombies work well
because these days we can do
swarms of enemies, and swarms
of 300 guys with guns would be
silly, but swarms of zombies
coming towards you would be--
WOLFF DOBSON: I don't know how
often you've been shot at, but
300 guys with guns--
it's a pretty short trip.
In fact, there's an e-talk years
ago from the Valve guys
about how they had to tone down
how much the bad guy shot
at you, because you just died.
Immediately.
It's like, you're suppressed
and flanked and it's over.
COLT MCANLIS: That would
be realistic.
WOLFF DOBSON: Sadly, realistic
shooters--
not nearly as much fun.
COLT MCANLIS: So we'll accept
the concept that aliens are
attacking from outer space and
make that a reality, but not a
guy shooting at you?
No, no, no.
It's stormtroopers, right?
WOLFF DOBSON: Well that's why
the stormtroopers couldn't hit
anybody, either.
They really have
that many guys.
COLT MCANLIS: They can hit
their head on the door,
apparently.
TODD KERPELMAN: I'm going to say
there's two things that I
like from the game design
perspective about zombies.
One is that you can basically
have the player shoot at them
all you want and no parents'
group is going to complain.
No one's really going
to raise a ruckus.
WOLFF DOBSON: Or say
German laws that--
TODD KERPELMAN: There's
that, too.
But if it's people, you start
to feel kind of bad about--
is it really OK to have
mowing down people?
But zombies--
you can shoot down a whole bunch
of them, limbs can go
flying off.
They make perfect enemies in
that sense in that it's
generally considered--
if you've got to have something
coming toward you
that you're going to kill,
zombies are good because
they're dead anyway.
WOLFF DOBSON: To all our undead
viewers, we'd just like
to say we love you.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah, but we
won't feel bad if we kill you.
[ZOMBIE NOISES]
TODD KERPELMAN: The other thing
is, I feel like people
judge the enemies in context
in terms of their
intelligence.
So basically, here's the deal--
you can have a zombie
coming towards me, and in a
video game, if he gets stuck
on this table and just keeps
walking towards me, stuck on
that table, that actually
feel somewhat realistic.
Because zombies are
sort of dumb.
If it was a person--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: A way to mask
our terrible path-finding
algorithms?
COLT MCANLIS: The programmers
are incompetent.
Throw zombies at it.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yes,
pretty much.
WOLFF DOBSON: Your expectation
for the post-dead is much
lower than your expectation--
TODD KERPELMAN: Your
expectation for the
path-finding abilities
of an enemy.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It also plays
into uncanny valley, right?
People look like zombies
in the uncanny
valley, so it's perfect.
It's the sweet spot.
[LAUGHTER]
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Actually
photo-realistic, real zombie
rendering, because it is
the uncanny valley.
TODD KERPELMAN: So when someone
says, hey, this
character's eyes look kind of
dead, you say thank you.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I worked so hard
to get those eyes just
dead enough.
TODD KERPELMAN: Colt,
anything to add?
COLT MCANLIS: Well, listen.
I think from the design
characteristics, it's as close
as you can get to actually
shooting another human and
still being legitimate
about it.
Plus there's just the concept
that video games very much
touch on the concept of
one against many.
It's always your hero vs the
world or the environment, and
at an evil realm, nothing
embodies that better than a
horde of zombies.
It just fits.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, if you
think about the number of
people Nathan Drake
has killed--
I mean you should feel
bad after awhile.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: And then he's
so charismatic in the
cut-scenes.
WOLFF DOBSON: It's like, I
murdered 27 people, and then I
made some jokes at my
ex-girlfriend, and then I
killed another 75 people.
So no, I think that's true.
I think the danger with having
zombies, and having the slow
guys who get hung up on the
train as they come at you--
besides the sort of breaking of
reality where you're like,
even a zombie ought to be able
to get over a garden hose or a
bench or something.
But I think the other problem is
that if you're building an
AI, and you're new at it, this
is the default thing you do,
which is make a bunch of guys
who come right at you.
And then your default gameplay
is to back up
and shoot at them.
And I'm so tired of that.
COLT MCANLIS: You didn't like "I
Made a Game with Zombies In
It?" I thought that
was fantastic.
WOLFF DOBSON: I mean--
I think--
[TIMER BEEPS]
TODD KERPELMAN: Time to reset
and go onto our next topic,
which actually is zombie AI.
And I think you had a
thesis about this.
Let's hear it.
WOLFF DOBSON: No, my thesis
was on educational child
development.
TODD KERPELMAN: Boring.
WOLFF DOBSON: I really think
that this concept--
I don't know if it's in
universal terms, but the term
that my crew calls it is
"kiting," where you're backing
and shooting a guy.
Running back and forth and
shooting a guy and shooting a
guy and shooting a guy.
It's the default thing that
happens with this kind of
really simple behavior,
is kiting.
And then the question is, are
you making kiting because it's
the thing that you
know how to make?
Or is it because we want the
character to be kiting?
As far as I'm concerned, from
a design perspective, if a
slow guy is chasing you, and
you're turning around every
now and then and shooting
at them--
if you will consistently outrun
that guy, that's not a
game anymore.
That's just like mowing
the lawn.
In fact, I actually find some of
the horde zombie games make
me feel like I could
just be out raking.
That'd be okay.
I'd get the leaves off my lawn
and I'd feel better about
killing all these dudes.
COLT MCANLIS: I'm sorry,
I didn't connect that.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Kiting
feels like a cheat.
When you're playing it you're
like, I know that there's this
AI radius that I could just step
into it for a second, he
starts lurching towards
me, I step out of it.
WOLFF DOBSON: And
I plug the guy.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It totally
breaks the game itself.
COLT MCANLIS: Only if it's
the default, though.
Because kiting-- if you
remember the original
Everquest, it was the thing to
do, to go get Spirit of the
Wolf and kite the drakes.
WOLFF DOBSON: I already have
Spirit of the Wolf.
COLT MCANLIS: You have
it all the time.
When we get Wolf Spirit--
that was the thing.
If you were two or three levels
below these drakes, you
couldn't beat them.
But if you had Spirit of the
Wolf, you could actually run
and kite them around.
So that was like, cool,
I found a hack.
So I wouldn't say that
kiting is always bad.
WOLFF DOBSON: I don't think it's
universally bad, but I
want it to be part of the
emotional part of the game.
And I think in that
case it is.
If you could imagine the game
where you have the giant--
well, like we were talking about
long ago, the big blue
monster in the "Pathways into
Darkness," where you're
backing up and unloading every
last clip into the guy.
And the whole point of the
game is, that guy is
unstoppable and all you
have is this puny gun.
And then all of a sudden, the
emotional content of this game
is the thing that you want.
There was an old PlayStation
2 game, and I can't
remember the name.
And I should have been looking
it up while you were talking,
where it was kind of hide and
seek where you played the
little scrawny girl being chased
by the giant monster.
And every time the giant monster
showed up, you had to
throw yourself into--
basically just hide.
You had to go hide inside a
closet or behind the curtain
or whatever, and cower
there and wait for
the monster to get--
and then leave again.
What was the name
of that game?
But it was a really
neat mechanic.
Unfortunately, the game didn't
quite work, but it was a neat
mechanic, because it is--
all of a sudden, kiting
is really--
it was like, oh my God,
I set it off.
I have to go hide.
COLT MCANLIS: So, real
quick question.
So you're the AI guy.
So if I were writing AI
correctly for a horde of
zombies, what should
I be doing?
What are some algorithms, what
are some techniques?
There's some people on the video
right now that I know
cannot wait to write
a good zombie AI.
What do they do?
WOLFF DOBSON: So the very core
thing you have to do with
zombies is that you don't want
to form a conga line.
And the conga line is, I'm
running away, I'm kiting these
guys, and they all--
TODD KERPELMAN: Start
funneling in.
WOLFF DOBSON: And then they
become this conga line.
So the way around that is to
use a technology called
"flocking." There's a very
famous paper by Craig Reynolds
which was about boids,
B-O-I-D-S. And the idea with
boids is, when you see a flock
of birds flying around, they
don't hit each other.
Well, if they do we don't
see it very often.
COLT MCANLIS: Socially
awkward birds.
[LAUGHTER]
WOLFF DOBSON: Hawkward.
But when the birds fly around,
they're kind of
following each other.
They're all going, and
there's a chaotic--
actually chaotic, mathematically
chaotic tumble
as the flock moves around.
And what they're actually doing,
what Craig Reynold's
model was, is to find a guy,
find his nearest couple of
neighbors, and try to match
speed and orientation with
those guys.
And it turns out that if
everybody is following that
very simple rule, you
get things to look
like flocking birds.
He's got a whole site called
Steering Behaviors.
And if you go check out Steering
Behaviors, it's all
kinds of very inexpensive ways
for dudes not to run into each
other as they're going along.
And you usually combine--
so now you have a horde,
who all kind
of look like a horde--
they're all sort of spread apart
and they're not smacking
into each other--
and actually there's lots
of us more about this.
In games like "Ages of Empires,"
there are actually
formations that they
like to form.
So as they get close to each
other, it's like, oh, there's
a bunch of areas on the board
where they're like, I like to
form in these things.
As they get close,
gravity kind of
pushes me into formation.
And that's a way where you
otherwise end up with all of
your catapults in front and
all of your shield men in
back, because the catapults
got there first.
You want them to-- oh, they've
got to the centroid of the
place they're supposed to go.
Now you feel this gravity to
pull you into formation.
COLT MCANLIS: And
with a flock--
I'm extending this.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: You
can't do that.
[INAUDIBLE]
COLT MCANLIS: There's an
important part there.
So with a zombie flock, who
controls where the flock goes?
WOLFF DOBSON: All right, so
either you have a single
leader, or the zombie
has one more rule.
So each zombie is standing there
and he's like, okay,
Kerp's over here and he's moving
this direction, so I
move in that direction.
And the way you do that--
it's a little bit of trig, but
basically you calculate his
vector, my vector, and the
speed, whatever, and then we
add them all together.
We'll post links afterwards
to some discussion of it.
But you also apply a vector
in the direction
that you want to go.
You average these vectors
together.
I want to be over there, but
Kerp's in the way, so I'll
blend around it.
And if you think about the way
like when I walk around, and--
except for when I walked into
the studio this morning.
I just about knocked
over the camera.
When you walk in, or when you're
walking around, I don't
sit there and like calculate a
plan to avoid every single
obstacle and then stick to that
plan as I walk around.
Instead I walk forward,
and like, oh
there's a thing there.
Okay, I'm going to
walk around that.
And that's essentially what
flocking is doing.
It's like, well I want to go
that way but Kerp's in the
way, so I'll walk with him
for a little bit until
he's out of the way.
And the closer I get to Kerp,
the stronger Kerp's vector to
push me back away from him is.
TODD KERPELMAN: That's because
I don't shower.
WOLFF DOBSON: So true.
But once I've made my distance
from everybody, then it's like
the gravity vector pulling me
toward-- the pull towards the
target now is much stronger.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So it's some
form of weighted average?
You increase the weight with
your flock buddies based on
your radius from them?
So a smaller radius like the
more it's like going in a way
that is much more important for
me and then when you're
kind of that like that nice
minimum there then you're like
true vector takes over?
WOLFF DOBSON: And likewise,
the other way around, too.
Which is that, if I'm too far
away from Kerp, I might feel a
little gravity to come back
to him, because I
want to stay in formation.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So there's
a minimum on that curve.
TODD KERPELMAN: All
right, stop it.
We have to move on.
Sorry.
COLT MCANLIS: Cool
stuff, though.
TODD KERPELMAN: Very
interesting stuff.
Post links.
We can all make our own
flocking behavior.
WOLFF DOBSON: Flocking
is really fun.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: We should
have a flock off.
[INAUDIBLE]
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Next
show-- flock off.
WOLFF DOBSON: This is a lot
of places we can go
here, but we're not.
COLT MCANLIS: Probably cancel
us in the next one.
TODD KERPELMAN: You had
me on flock buddy.
[LAUGHTER]
TODD KERPELMAN: What is that
your scariest moment that
you've run into in a game?
[LAUGHTER]
TODD KERPELMAN: Scariest
moment in a game.
You're not allowed to say the
"Resident Evil" one, dogs,
because that's what everyone
thinks of first.
And you get bonus points if
your answer involves a
non-traditionally scary game.
But you don't have to go
for the bonus points.
I'm not going to go for
the bonus points.
WOLFF DOBSON: I think we have
to start with John.
TODD KERPELMAN: We'll
start with John.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Well, I'm
going to go back to my
standard game.
Demon Souls.
[LAUGHER]
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I haven't played
it in months, but the
DLC just came out,
so I'm going to
start playing it again.
No, but actually there was in
"Demon Souls," which is "Dark
Souls 1," there's a stage that
you spawn into to the world,
and you're walking down this
tunnel, and there's just this
massive dragon.
Way, way, way big.
Essentially, the dragon takes
over the entire environment
that you're in.
And you're walking and fireballs
are coming out, and
you're like, what am
I supposed to do?
You can't even get close
to this guy.
And that was just terrifying.
It takes so long and eventually
you realize--
you don't actually attack him.
You use the environment
to attack him.
And that's the only way to beat
him, but for the longest
time you're sitting there
like, what am
I supposed to do?
You're shooting arrows at him
and you're just getting
slaughtered, again and
again and again.
TODD KERPELMAN: Cole.
Scariest moment in a game.
COLT MCANLIS: I'm trying
to get the bonus
points on this one.
I don't know if you're going
to give them to me.
WOLFF DOBSON: "Mario Galaxy."
COLT MCANLIS: "Metroid." The
first "Metroid," when you
actually encounter a Metroid.
You go through this entire game,
you fight Ridley, you go
through all the areas.
And then when you first
encounter the Metroid, you
realize what that thing
can do to you.
The only way either kill
it is either to freeze
it and rocket it--
and if you miss it, it
attaches to you.
I remember inching, pixel by
pixel, through that game.
Because as soon as that
Metroid-- as soon as one of
his pixels came on screen,
he was on top of you.
And man, I remember
just being frozen.
Just the haunting concept
was like--
this Metroid's going to
get me, this Metroid's
going to get me.
I inched the entire way.
In the follow up for
the Game Boy, the
"Metroid 2," same concept.
Because "Metroid 2" there were
Metroids everywhere.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: That
was one of the best
Metroid games ever.
COLT MCANLIS: It was amazing.
Even though it was like this
the whole time. "Super
Metroid" was the same way.
When you finally beat
everything and
you got down into--
there was a four-tier zigzag
until you got to the final
Mother Brain room.
It was still just as haunting
as it ever was, just this
desolate environment and you
know-- you know that there's a
Metroid like seven pixels away,
and you're about to be
in a firefight.
Man, that was just--
to this day, If I see something
shaped like a
Metroid, I just wet myself.
TODD KERPELMAN: We will have to
experiment with that later.
WOLFF DOBSON: I have
one right here.
TODD KERPELMAN: So for me,
I'm going to pick a
couple moments in games--
traditionally scary games--
"Dead Space" and "Resident
Evil 2," I
think, where the game--
the entire way, lulls
you into thinking
certain areas are safe.
Like in "Dead Space," it was
this save point place, or
maybe it was the store
machine or something.
It was the same point.
And in "Resident Evil," it was
that loading animation while
the door opened and you got
into the next room.
In both of those, there was
one point in each of those
games where all of a sudden,
a monster came in.
When you were like, okay, I'm
relaxed, I'm at a save point.
I get out and all of a sudden,
a monster drops
down from the screen.
Or in "Resident Evil," you open
up the door, the loading
animation goes, and then
two zombies come in.
And both of those just freaked
me out, because up until that
point, the game had done such a
good job of training me that
when you're at this point, you
can relax, it is safe.
WOLFF DOBSON: That's such a good
emotional manipulation.
There are horror games where
they play the safe music, and
you're in the safe place, and
you feel it for awhile, and
then they turn on you.
But they wait for like half
the game to do it to you.
It's so important to have
those ups and downs.
Otherwise you're just always
being attacked,
and it's not scary.
TODD KERPELMAN: I'm waiting for
the moment when the actual
safe room--
in "Resident Evil," the safe
room with the typewriter and
the good music--
WOLFF DOBSON: I can hum
the music if you like.
I still associate that music
with a happy place.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yes.
One day, that place isn't
going to be happy.
[INAUDIBLE]
WOLFF DOBSON: So mine
concerns a story.
So back in the Dreamcast days,
there was a game called
"Carrier." And if you go back
and play it now, it is
comically, comically
silly looking.
But at the time, my imagination
was doing a lot of
work for me.
I remember I was living in San
Francisco, and I was playing
at night, waiting for my wife
to come home from chorus.
I'm sitting there, and there are
these little baby things
that come out of a pod,
and they sort of
crawl along the ground.
You have to--
you have your little arc welder
that you're sitting
there zapping, walking
slowly backwards,
zapping these things.
And kind of walking over them.
And I didn't feel like
I was frightened.
I know how to--
I was kiting them.
I knew what to do.
You come back up and
shoot these guys.
And then you set off another
one, back up
and shoot the guys.
They made this kind of gross
noise as you're doing it, and
I had to go back and forth
across this corridor full of
those things, like three
or four times.
The game was awash
in backtracking
So then my wife comes home, so
I go and save, and I go into
the kitchen to start
washing the dishes.
And I'm holding the sponge, and
I'm wiping the thing, and
then I hear this squish
behind me.
And I just spun around, and I
grabbed the sponge, and suds
are going everywhere.
I'm like, what are you doing?
And she's like, oh there
was a nectarine.
It was moldy, so I dropped it.
I was just like--
[HEAVY BREATHING]
WOLFF DOBSON: And I just hadn't
realized, in three
hours, my anxiety had been
completely maxed out.
If I'd been holding a gun
instead of a sponge, there
would have been six holes in
the kitchen at that point.
COLT MCANLIS: I like to
cook with a handgun.
Omelettes taste better
with a glock.
WOLFF DOBSON: I'm like,
bam, dishes are done.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Guys,
we do have some
feedback from Youtube.
Someone says "Demon Souls"
is a masterpiece.
So we do have a John
McCutchan fan.
Not expecting that.
COLT MCANLIS: Is the person
wearing plaid?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It's
[? Rodimir ?]
[? Pitsoff. ?]
has not discussed what
he's wearing.
And then we have--
TODD KERPELMAN: What
are you wearing?
WOLFF DOBSON: No, no, no.
Mute.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: [INAUDIBLE]
says "Super Mario" was
extremely scary.
It didn't specify
which platform.
TODD KERPELMAN: I'd like some
more details about what was
scary about "Super Mario."
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: When I got
my first NES, I was
like six years old.
And I could barely play video
games, and because of that,
Mario was actually terrifying.
You get to the world 8-1, you
have to do four jumps in
succession, and there was just a
pillar one Mario-width wide.
And having to do that,
when I finally--
I would get terrified, because
I've only got three men.
And I'd have to go all the
way back to 1-1 when
I screw this up.
Eventually you figure out the
rhythm and that's fine, but
when I was a far worse
game-player than I am today,
it was terrifying.
WOLFF DOBSON: Would you say
you were more anxious or
frightened?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, I was
probably more anxious.
WOLFF DOBSON: Anxious is a
slightly different emotion.
My story was a little bit more
about anxiety rather than
fear, but it's the same
sort of thing.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It was fear of
having to start the game
again, because there's
no save point.
WOLFF DOBSON: So you're just
going back to that, over and
over again, with Demon Souls.
This is what I'm hearing.
It's like, the horror
of your life is
having to redo something.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Anxiety
WOLFF DOBSON: So actually I
would add one more, which is
"Minecraft." It can be scary,
because you've built this safe
world, and all a sudden there's
dudes it in your
castle, blowing it up.
And you're like, how
did that happen?
But actually I was playing with
my daughter, and we were
running around, and we fell into
a cave, and fell really
far down this cave.
And we're running around.
And we'd never actually
done much caving--
or spelunking, shall I say--
up until that point.
You get down there, and there
are lot more monsters, and you
can hear them crawling around
in the [? weeds. ?]
As I was like, yeah okay, just
do my pickax, just dig our way
out of this.
But she was like, I don't
like it here.
This is a bad place.
Let's go up and sleep and it
will be daylight again.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So "Minecraft"
for me, was really
scary in two ways.
One, at night, when you have
to go into your safe house.
And you just know that if they
get through your defenses,
it's out of control.
There's not much you can
do at that point.
And then two, sometimes I fell
deep in a cave, and whenever I
do make it back up to the
surface, I don't think I'll
ever be able to find
my house again.
[LAUGHTER]
WOLFF DOBSON: There's a level
of unhappiness there.
I know you're talking about.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I guess
I'll just start anew.
TODD KERPELMAN: Claustrophobic,
scared of the
dark, lost--
WOLFF DOBSON: And monsters
growling as
you're digging around.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: And you might
dig in one direction for the
longest time, thinking you're
going up, and then you hit the
purple rock where you can't
really break through.
And you're like, I need to find
the shortest path around
this huge mound of
unbreakable rock.
Only to get up and see that,
a, your house is probably
destroyed and you'll never
find it again.
WOLFF DOBSON: Or you
accidentally dig under a lake.
COLT MCANLIS: What would make
that is if you climbed all the
way back to the surface and you
found out that apes were
running the place.
TODD KERPELMAN: What a twist.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Spoiler.
TODD KERPELMAN: All
right, let's move
on to our next question.
Another zombie one or
the vampire one?
TODD KERPELMAN: How are
we doing on time?
TODD KERPELMAN: Good.
2:36.
I think we got time.
Let's go with one
more zombie one.
In our various forms of media,
books, games, or movies, do we
prefer the traditional slow,
shambling zombies, or the "28
Days Later," "Dawn of the Dead"
fast-running zombies.
COLT MCANLIS: I'm just
going to jump out.
"28 Days Later" fast
zombie, right.
So the fast zombie is to the
regular zombie as shiny
vampire is to regular vampire.
This is an abomination.
Listen, a zombie is not-- a
single zombie is not the
reason you're afraid
of zombies.
It's the horde.
It's the flock.
It's this unending wave
of deathness.
What kills you with zombies
is not one guy.
It's the concept that you're
never going to get out.
That's what's terrifying with
zombies, and you know what?
Fast zombies break
that entirely.
Because it's just a different
ballgame.
It's a sparkly vampire
of zombies.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I don't think
that necessarily breaks it,
but I agree with you.
What's frightening about zombies
is not just that
there's zombies near you.
It's that like 99% of all
humans on the planet are
zombies, and it's kind
of hopeless.
You're in a shopping mall, and
you're up on the roof and
looking out, and it's like,
well, I see a lot of zombies
and I see one dude way over
there who's not a zombie.
And then it's just
a sea of zombies.
And you're like, what am I
even trying to do here?
I can outrun these guys,
but where do I run to?
There's nothing left.
That's the frightening part
of zombies for me.
COLT MCANLIS: The cool
thing is half of
them are your neighbors.
I served with Ted in the PTA.
Now I get to hit him
with a shovel.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Again.
[LAUGHTER]
TODD KERPELMAN: I think
you've turned me to
your point of view.
[INAUDIBLE]
WOLFF DOBSON: I'm
going to stand
with multi-speed zombies.
[INAUDIBLE]
WOLFF DOBSON: I'm going to
stand with multi-speed
zombies, because I
think part of the
zombie fear isn't just--
I mean, there's the concept that
zombies were the sort of
Cold War fear of conformity
kind of metaphor.
You're like, what?
It's like, no, no, no, really.
And also, again, it was reused
as consumerism, like on "Dawn
of the Dead" and things
like that.
But for me, it's about
infection.
It's about SARS.
It's about all the bad things
that can happen to you.
And one bite and you're hosed.
To me, that's the zombie fear.
And so speedy zombies are just
fast-moving things that want
to infect me, as opposed
to slow-moving things.
COLT MCANLIS: But again,
it breaks the mold.
So if you have a sparkly vampire
that doesn't blow up
in the daylight, that
breaks the rules.
Now, if you've got
a fast zombie--
WOLFF DOBSON: They have rings.
They have a ring that
saves them .
Haven't you been watching?
COLT MCANLIS: No, that's
the Vampire Diaries.
That's a different one.
WOLFF DOBSON: See, you
have been watching.
[GROANS]
WOLFF DOBSON: Busted!
TODD KERPELMAN: Do these
vampires wear bikinis when
they go out fighting?
COLT MCANLIS: They should.
Back to the point.
The fact is that--
[LAUGHTER]
WOLFF DOBSON: Vampire
tan lines.
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: So you've got
a fast-moving, infectious
organism that doesn't respond
to gunfire or being on fire.
That breaks the mold.
Like you can--
[INAUDIBLE]
COLT MCANLIS: I'm sorry,
but you are wrong.
And you think that
part of sales OK
WOLFF DOBSON: Audience, you
have to help me here.
Tell us how wrong Colt is.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: If you
were Patient Zero--
who do you eat first?
How do you spread yourself
most effectively?
WOLFF DOBSON: Dude, there
was a cool little game.
TODD KERPELMAN: This
is a good topic.
Let's reset and start this.
[INAUDIBLE]
TODD KERPELMAN: So am I actually
looking to spread?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Well, your brain
has been consumed by the
zombie virus, and you just have
the impulse to spread.
WOLFF DOBSON: You start
with Madagascar.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yes,
that is true.
WOLFF DOBSON: You haven't
played the plague game?
TODD KERPELMAN: You've always
got to start in Madagascar,
because they shut off their
ports right away.
WOLFF DOBSON: The President of
Madagascar is like, somebody
sniffled somewhere.
We're shutting the ports.
TODD KERPELMAN: The internet
knows what
we're talking about.
You guys know.
WOLFF DOBSON: Madagascar.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: You want to
spread as fast as possible and
as robustly as possible, so you
don't pick just one class
of the population.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah.
I got to go to an airport.
I feel like that's where
I got to go.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: There's
a lot of security
at airports, though.
There's a lot of guns.
Let's say you're
in a hospital.
You're sick.
You just wake up and now
you've got to eat.
And you are the last surviving
member of your new race.
COLT MCANLIS: Ooh,
I like that.
That's creepy.
TODD KERPELMAN: So really,
it's about
it's about me surviving.
COLT MCANLIS: As a new zombie
that can affect anything.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: You don't
want to go extinct.
Your entire species would go
extinct if you don't succeed.
TODD KERPELMAN: The thing about
waking up at the hospital--
the nice thing there is, there's
probably a bunch of
victims ready.
In bad, sedated, not really
ready to fight back.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: But are they
going to spread very well?
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah
it depends.
A lot of these guys-- well, I
guess it depends on the virus.
If I'm sick and I get bitten
by zombie virus, does that
make the healthy again except
for the zombie part?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I don't think
you've addressed the taste of
the people you're biting.
If you're at a hospital,
I don't know if
you'd want to eat them.
What about a jail?
In jail, you're in a confined
space, the people are forced
to be there, closed
confined quarters.
Something to think about.
TODD KERPELMAN: I'm not sure
about the jail, because it's
very easy to bottle in.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: If I was a
zombie, I would just be like,
who's going to taste the best?
I won't spoil my appetite.
I'm going to really
think about this.
COLT MCANLIS: So you'd go to
library, because you're going
for brains, right?
So you'd want the beefiest
brains that
spend the most exercise.
Libraries, universities.
That's the best that I--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: But you
know veal, right?
COLT MCANLIS: Google,
yeah , Google.
You would start at Google.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Just like veal,
you don't want a brain
that's been too exercised,
because then
it's a little tough.
WOLFF DOBSON: It's
a little stringy.
So there was a game called
Influenza, which I think was a
[INAUDIBLE]
game.
And yeah, your job is to
basically take control of
people who are sick and
have them go and
sneeze or throw up.
And you have upgrades like Vomit
Linger and things like
this, which is like how long--
[LAUGHTER]
WOLFF DOBSON: When you're
working on mechanics for your
games, make sure you have
that check box.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It's
just this perfume.
COLT MCANLIS: That's our new
team shirts +1 Vomit Linger.
GDL Google Games Chat.
TODD KERPELMAN: So John,
you didn't say--
who would you bite first?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I think
I would go for the
least mobile first.
WOLFF DOBSON: He's just lazy.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I'm going to
increase my numbers really
easily without much
threat, without
exerting a lot of energy.
But again, we're going to be
this mass of slow-moving--
you can take the guys
off the edge.
It's like a family
of penguins.
WOLFF DOBSON: It's a phalanx,
if you will.
Have you read "World War Z?" If
you have not, if you like
supernatural books
or action books,
"World War Z" is amazing.
But yeah, this is one
of the problems.
It's basically like,
okay, you've gained
control of your zombie--
if you've got all the survivors
in one place, now
you need to rid the
world of zombies.
How do you go about that?
And they have an interesting
solution.
I won't spoil it.
"World War Z"-- read it.
TODD KERPELMAN: I think that's
our fifth topic.
And we covered that
pretty well.
Except I'm still thinking
airport.
I'd still go for the airport.
There's a great you get there
[INAUDIBLE]
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Certainly, if
you could get some planes
taking off with a couple
zombies, so that by the time
they land, it's like a
zombie party plane.
WOLFF DOBSON: How is that
plane going to land?
Reinforced cockpit doors.
So only the pilot will
be able to land.
The pilot then has a choice.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Hopefully
the pilot chooses to--
WOLFF DOBSON: But if it does
that, then they're just going
to bite sharks, and then
you have zombie sharks.
COLT MCANLIS: But that's
what you want.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I think
you just won the game.
COLT MCANLIS: With
freakin' lasers.
TODD KERPELMAN: We're going to
finish out with "what are you
playing." We'll start
with Wolff first.
WOLFF DOBSON: So I've been
playing a whole bunch of
things, but the game that struck
me as an interesting
discussion topic is "Horn."
Just came out--
I've been playing
on my Nexus 7.
It's published by Zynga.
It's a very interesting game.
It's got touches of "Ico" in it,
or however you say that.
Which is the old PlayStation 2
game where you have the space
princess that you
carry around--
drag around by her hand.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: "King
of Space."
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, and
then solve puzzles.
And it also has, definitely,
overtones of "Zelda." What
struck me about it as I was
playing it, and I was enjoying
it, and it's fun--
is that it signaled to me that
the era of second or third
generation PlayStation 2 games
are now available mobile.
I was sitting there playing on
my Nexus 7, which is not a
particularly expensive
device and thinking
wow, this looks nice.
It's like late PlayStation 2--
oh wow, we've come--
that was quick.
So that's what I found very
interesting about it.
It's fun so far.
The combat mechanics are
very touch-sensitive.
TODD KERPELMAN: Actually, that
makes me look forward to being
able to play some of the other
classic PlayStation 2 or DS or
whatever games that I never
got around to playing.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, I've
seen a couple of them.
They ported for the--
shoot, what is the
name of the game.
Come back to me and
I'll have it.
TODD KERPELMAN: So, still
playing "Skyrim." But I also
started playing--
[INAUDIBLE]
TODD KERPELMAN: I actually, two
days ago was like, crap, I
got to play something
different.
So that when I go to this--
WOLFF DOBSON: We have
a terrible job.
We're forced to play games so we
have something interesting
to talk about.
TODD KERPELMAN: I had work to
do, but it was like, I can't
do my work.
I've got to play something
different.
And so I played "Faster
Than Light," FTL.
I started playing that.
And boy, I die a lot.
WOLFF DOBSON: You have to
play a game that we
haven't talked about.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: That's a rule.
[INAUDIBLE]
TODD KERPELMAN: I do have to
say, my crew is terrible at
fighting fires, I think.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: You use the
airlocks to fight the fires.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah, except
that apparently, one of the
fires broke out in the
oxygen station.
WOLFF DOBSON: I feel like
there's a secondary safety
protocol we weren't following.
TODD KERPELMAN: I emptied
out the air, I
closed all the doors.
To fire was out, and I was
like, now what do I do.
I was left without oxygen.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Get every
person into that room.
TODD KERPELMAN: I tried, and
they didn't make it.
WOLFF DOBSON: I like playing
simulators where everyone dies
in the cold, black
void of space.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I was talking
to Vince about "FTL," and he
was saying eventually you can
get a teleporter, and you can
teleport to the enemy ship
and fight hand-to-hand.
He said he did that, and he left
his automated attack bots
going, and they destroyed
the ship.
The enemy ships and his
whole crew went.
You have to make sure that if
you teleport over, you get
back over before
the ship goes.
TODD KERPELMAN: Colt, what
are you playing?
Besides "Dark Legends."
COLT MCANLIS: Well, actually
I have been playing "Dark
Legends," because--
TODD KERPELMAN: It's for work.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Well
it actually is.
So since last episode, we said
hey, let's show off a great
Halloween game.
And I was level one when I
started a week and a half ago.
TODD KERPELMAN: I thought you
had mailed these guys, was
hanging and shooting booze.
COLT MCANLIS: I've been playing
the entire time.
And you know what?
The game has gotten better and
better and better the longer
I've played it.
It's really hard to
communicate what--
WOLFF DOBSON: Are they
pushing updates?
COLT MCANLIS: All of
the space-time--
sorry, I mean the content--
my experience with the game has
gotten better and better.
You've got to remember, I was
addicted to "Everquest" back
in the day.
My father and I, we each
had two accounts.
And that was our father-son
bonding, was we would sit down
and play "Everquest" together.
And then I had to do some stuff,
and so he took over all
four accounts, and then got
two more computers and was
able to six box an "Everquest"
guild by himself.
Padre, if you're watching, mad
props for your MMO skills.
WOLFF DOBSON: I thought this
is why you had children.
Daddy needs you to tank.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I need
a gold farm now.
COLT MCANLIS: I've heard
that phrase before.
So I am very clued in to
what makes good MMOs.
And "Dark Legends" got cooler
and cooler and cooler.
Because it was a different
mechanic.
It was originally built for
mobile, and so it took a
little bit of time for me to
understand why they changed
some things, and how it
translated to the native
client build.
But the more I got into it, the
more it made sense, and
the more fun I started having
with it, so yeah, I've been
playing "Dark Legends,"
believe it or not.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I got a
new game this week.
Yes, I picked up the new
"X-COM." It's great.
I never really got
into "X-COM" when
it was a DOS game.
And it's now the exact same game
I watched my friends play
as a kid, and I'm loving it.
And the transition to
3D is excellent.
It's still the exact
same game.
You're building out
your base--
WOLFF DOBSON: I hear
the interface--
I mean, the interface in the DOS
one was fairly terrifying.
TODD KERPELMAN: You had to spend
half your time making
sure you ordered
enough bullets.
WOLFF DOBSON: There was that,
and just the grid of buttons,
with incomprehensible
icons on them.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It's still
a very complex game.
It's still grid-based, but
you're working with an-- at
least, I'm playing on the PS3,
so I'm working with an analog
stick, and they do a really
great job of mapping the
controls to the console.
And it is a lot of fun.
TODD KERPELMAN: How you named
your squad after either
friends, coworkers,
famous people?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I'm too lazy.
I'm too lazy to do that.
Although I have a friend who
keeps telling me on Facebook--
he's like, you just
died last night.
WOLFF DOBSON: I do
all the time.
I name all my characters
after my coworkers.
TODD KERPELMAN: I started doing
that in "FTL," but they
die too quickly.
It's not worth it.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: In FTL, they're
really disposable.
[LAUGHTER]
WOLFF DOBSON: Have you
seen the way I play?
The way I play, would like
because we defeated visit we
defeated the UFO attack on the
bodies of thousands of special
forces people.
I don't know how you
play "X-COM."
COLT MCANLIS: The famous Zapp
Brannigan quote is that, "How
did you defeat the killbots?"
WOLFF DOBSON: "They had a
built-in kill limit, and so I
just sent wave after wave
of my own men."
COLT MCANLIS: Until they
reset themselves.
WOLFF DOBSON: And we'd do
it again, right men?
Men?
COLT MCANLIS: Love me
some Zapp Brannigan.
"Futurama." More episodes,
please, please, please.
WOLFF DOBSON: Every mission I
go on is a suicide mission.
And again, this is also my
motto playing "X-COM" and
similar games.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So "X-COM,"
unlike FTL, in "X-COM" I'm
really enjoying the RPG mechanic
of my players,
despite being too lazy
to name them.
WOLFF DOBSON: I love you, AA.
COLT MCANLIS: Do you put
all of them in plaid?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: They come
with preset, good names.
And some of them I have almost
max rank, and I'm pretty
concerned about them, just
because they're so powerful.
COLT MCANLIS: I can just imagine
John being like, okay
everybody, well we're
in plaid today.
My children.
I'm bundling you up and then
throwing you into the fray.
WOLFF DOBSON: Quick, there's
a fire in the oxygen room.
I'm afraid I'm going
to have to vent it.
[LAUGHTER]
WOLFF DOBSON: Little frozen,
plaid bodies in space.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: In FTL, they
have the plaid meter.
Spend enough time on my ship.
[LAUGHTER]
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: They're
in plaid.
[LAUGHTER]
I think that is a perfect
note to end this
Halloween episode on.
Remember kids, forward this
video your friends or Louis
Gray will get you.
WOLFF DOBSON: Louis
Gray, Louis Gray.
Don't say his name three
times or he'll pop up.
TODD KERPELMAN: And we will
see you in two weeks.
Happy Halloween.
[MUSIC PLAYING]